the jurogan experience the thing that i
keep going back to
is like at the end of the day
my head on my pillow do i feel good
about the choices i'm making and do i
stand strong in my beliefs
yes then i'm not going to let what
someone in idaho has to say about
what i'm doing well people want
absolutes right whether it comes to
recovery from drugs and alcohol or
whether it comes
from anything they do they don't want
you to deviate from the path
and they want you to always be helpless
in the face of your addictions
right this is this is the thought
process we're trying to a lot of the
12-step programs
that you're helpless in the face of your
addictions um
i don't know if that's true i have never
had a drug or an alcohol addiction i've
never had
that kind of a compulsion so i don't
know but what i read about you
is that you think of yourself now as
california
sober like please tell me what the [ __ ]
california sober
i saw this smile on your face like start
to form and it just made me so
happy all right well so
part of my process now
is like not defining the parameters
publicly because i don't feel like it's
anybody's business but
me and my treatment team but
it's a term that a lot of people use uh
to identify this
path of moderation with
the help of some green plants you know
what i'm saying
i do and so green
is the key word and and that's
that's that yeah but it's it's such a
loaded subject that even bringing it up
you have to kind of guard
yourself from the way other people are
going to perceive what you're doing
right i'm a celebrity and i guard
everything i say
even if i'm speaking my truth i still
have to guard it to some degree because
i don't
i i'm working so hard not to offend
anyone you know so it's like yes but
every aspect of my life is that way now
now do you find
that this green stuff makes you
more relaxed in dealing with the
anxieties of
life or like what is well the green
stuff is weird
well just like yeah yeah yeah um
[Laughter]
yeah we'll just like call it what it is
um yeah it's it's something
that you know
it helps and it also like is is
something that you can use
for different things it can it it helped
me
learn how to meditate at first you know
it was a lot easier to
smoke a little bit and then meditate
than it was to just
go in without with just like the most
clear mind
it helped me build a relationship with
meditation to where i don't need it
to meditate anymore you know there's
there's things there's benefits to it
and i think there's also just a
sense of security and knowing that um
that even if i'm having a bad night and
i turn to that that's not going to kill
me right you know i guess he'd get there
without weed
you can you totally can yeah i just
found that like
weed gets you there quicker yeah just a
little bit
[Laughter]
um and i just yeah i
there's it doesn't hurt you that's the
thing it's like it doesn't hurt your
body
but i do know people that have gotten
addicted to weed you know
yeah and that's something to be mindful
of for sure
but i i have not a physical addiction
though it's not an addiction like
alcohol
or benzos or coke or anything like that
it's a it's an impulse it's a
psychological addiction that's what it
is
yeah i mean maybe for some people it's a
physical addiction like really really
rare
but for most people there's no there's
nothing happens when you get off it
there's no withdrawals
yeah yeah i think that it's something to
be like
mindful of just like anything new in my
life
i kind of i have a treatment team that i
run things by
so you run weed by them yeah what would
they say
whatever you know i came out of i went
to treatment
for like a relapse i relapsed in 2019
and it was heavy and it was a heavy one
explain to everybody
what you went through because it's like
it sounds normal but you almost died
so i overdosed on heroin
and crack that was well the heroin was
laced with
fentanyl and um
i od'd in 2018
and that experience was
a near-death experience for me the
doctors told me i had five to ten
minutes
before it was too late um
when they found me i was blue i was
there's blood just i had three strokes a
heart attack
and multiple organ failure
and i still have brain brain damage from
it
and what kind of brain damage so i have
blind spots
in my vision and i also had hearing loss
from everything um the blind spots are
like like i don't
i don't drive um i can't unless i was on
like an open
dirt road and i could just like i just
don't
want to put other people at risk on the
roads um
so you like normally you see everything
like you see everything in front of you
right now no so
even like your face i see your eyeballs
when i'm looking at your eyes i see your
eyes but i don't see your
nose your mouth or even your microphone
what do you see
this part it looks like i i looked at
the sun
you know when you're a kid and you look
at the sun because someone told you not
to because i'm that kid
yeah it's like that when you look at the
sun and like or
even like a camera flash and it kind of
goes like greenish bluish
it's not black but it's you can't see
and it's just like a blind spot that
takes over kind of like everybody's
bottom half of their face whoa and so my
favorite could you focus on someone's
bottom half of their face if they were
supposed to
look down i have to look down at
people's mouths when they talk so you
only see like a stripe
like a strip of their face yeah
literally just exactly where you put it
i could see the top of your fingers but
not your hand
and so for the first
few months like i couldn't read out of a
book
um i was so hard to like tweezing my
eyebrows couldn't do that at first
how do you live how do you live exactly
my brows are extremely important to me
so that was a huge thing fabulous
thank you so much thank you you're doing
a great job whatever you can see
thank you uh whatever you can see
[Laughter]
you're a savage oh my god um but yeah
it's so there was things that
and i had to ask like opinions on my
outfit like i couldn't
wow couldn't see what shoes went with my
outfit is this getting any better
no so it plateaued after six months like
whatever it would be
after six months after the overdose
would be what it'll be for
the rest of my life and so and this is
from the stroke
wow so this
this experience that you had your
you had a heart attack you had strokes
you have this vision issue that's going
to exist for the rest of your life
so i'm sure everyone around you then
was like hey you got to stay the [ __ ]
away from all drugs forever
like this is it like we almost lost you
this could be it for your life
so how do you how do you ease into weed
from there
so it's it took a lot of time um
what was the impetus like what what led
you to do it
um what led me to do it actually was i
got
into recovery from my bulimia and
i thought all right this is an addiction
i've had
since i was 12. how is it that
everything started at 12 for me
i was like how is it that i finally
found
recovery from this but yet i'm still
struggling with substances
i thought well what am i doing with food
that's different
and i wasn't looking at it from a
dogmatic approach
this all or nothing mentality you know i
was
eating taco bell and letting myself keep
it down
and not throwing it up anymore and
that to me was a new
the normal person like doesn't know that
that
of course that's what you do with
chocobo you like you let it sit
this was a new [ __ ] idea for me i was
like my mind was blown
you would eat you would go on a bend or
eat a taco bell and then just like okay
out of the pool boys but pretty much
pretty much
every time you ate something terrible
like that you knew that you were gonna
throw it up yeah yeah and
um so when i when i went
after i had relapsed in 2019
on the hard stuff um i went back to
the treatment center i'd gone to right
after uh
treatment and i just said to them
i was like i i think i need to
allow myself the ability to really try
this middle path and not
like before when i said i was on a
middle path but really was like
going was like really trying to party
like i'm i mean like
if i want to smoke then i'll let myself
smoke and
i just i kind of came to terms with
i kind of came up with that and talked
it through with my treatment team back
home
and let everyone know like hey this is i
have to own my truth
and um and my treatment team said okay
like we'll support you and stand by you
what do you need from us
that will help and it was at that point
that like i started getting this thing
called the vivitrol shot
which is um a shot that blocks all the
opiate receptors
in your brain so if
you i mean honestly even if i were to
get like in a
bad injury and go to the hospital i
couldn't even
get opiates in a hospital because like
my body will reject them so much it goes
into withdrawals immediately
really yeah and but why do you need that
um so it also helps with bulimia because
what people don't realize about bulimia
is that it helps bulimia when you throw
up your
opiate receptors go off in your brain so
sometimes people actually get
addicted to the high you get
after throwing up rather than
like people think that it's like there's
actually a physical component in your
brain
that people get addicted to um and
that's why people become addicted to
the feeling that euphoria after you
that's crazy i had no idea i thought it
just you always felt every time i've
ever thrown up
i felt terrible i never would have
imagined that there's
i guess because you're sick i think like
if you're not sick
maybe you don't feel terri i don't i
don't unders i don't know but now i'm
thinking of trying it
no no no no oh my god no no no
oh i'm kidding i'm kidding listen i'll
never be believing i [ __ ]
i eat like a pig and
that's okay it's okay like a pig thank
you yeah if that's what
if that's what makes you happy then like
own your truth and live it
you know so i i'm still curious as to
like
what about weed made you
want to even introduce it into your life
after
working so hard to be sober and having
this
horrible experience with overdosing
right so
i dealt i often say and this is really
hard for people to hear sometimes but i
think that
drugs saved my life at times
because had i not had something to
medicate with
i wouldn't be here i would have taken my
life by now i've dealt with
suicidal ideation since i was seven
years old and
that's just something that's always been
a part of my journey i don't know why
but
depression has i've been i've had a
journey with that
um there was a period of time where i
thought to myself
i'm so miserable i'm still sober now i'm
sober again
this is after the overdose i'm so sober
and still so unhappy what am i doing
and i got to this place where i kept
thinking
if i pick up you know that term
um i had been told so many times
by people in recovery or treatment team
whatever
not this treatment team but a different
one that if i picked up that i would die
and i i thought to myself
what kind of life um
am i living if i'm miserable 24 7 and if
i feel like the bottom is gonna drop
out i'm gonna die like that's not really
a life to live and so i thought what if
there's some sort
of relief in between that's not gonna
kill me that's
not um that's not
i don't know super dangerous you know
what is it and i thought
well i live in california know
why not a little weed and so i tried it
and
it wasn't so bad and i began to
appreciate what it could do for me
it stopped me from going to the other
things a lot of people say that weed is
gateway drug
but what people don't know is that it
can also be
a drug that can provide a little bit of
relief for people
who feel like when they get that low
they're either gonna pick up something
really dark
really heavy or
something more ominous you know
yeah i don't buy that gateway [ __ ] i
don't either i really don't i don't
fire with anything also i hate even
calling weed a drug because it's
a sacred plant like it's sacred medicine
and so i'm talking like a healer yeah i
am i
am but it but it is it's like it's under
the category of
super plant medicine medicine so there's
there's definitely some
magical properties to it catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience